vous êtes toujours à la recherche du
grand amour ou non non non ça il est
arrivé non vous cherchez pas non vous
laisse arriver quoi de voir exactement
mais le grand amour un jour il tape à ta
porte tu crois que c'est le facteur
c'est lui je peux le dis moi moi ça
m'arrive mais non c'est être acteur
j'ai fermé ma gueule l'armée chérèque
est-ce que vous pensez que c'est plus
compliqué de trouver l'amour quand on
est connu
certains pour une femme ouais parce
qu'un mec un make way regardez alors
avec vous regardez castagne on n'est
même pas l'âge non mais tu vois des mecs
des mecs des mecs vieux débats tendus
pour le oui non tu vois alors qu'une
femme c'est plus compliqué l'âge pour
une femme ouais non non moi ça vaut mais
je trouve qu'un homme il a plus de
liberté c'est sûr de choix non mais en
plus c'est vrai clément jugé policé pas
ça c'est pas ça que je veux dire c'est
qu'un homme qui très forte réussite il
va trouver toujours une femme n'importe
quel âge peut importe qui va être assez
merveilleux
elle en a mis à une femme qui réussit il
faut trouver un homme qui réussit encore
plus en fait sinon le legs leur pressing
ouais c'est ça regardez là il m'a
regardé la plus réussie que son mec tu
vois et guettier à ça se passe ça fait
dix ans qu'ils sont ensemble est roulez
jeunesse
c'est très bien mais là il ya ce qu'on
fait c'est plus compliqué de trouver un
mec quand on est je pense que l'ana
raisons effectivement c'est plus c'est
plus compliqué parce que c'est d'abord
pour une femme la célébrité c'est
toujours un peu suspect et que que chez
un homme
forcément on lui prend val parée de tous
les artifices de pouvoir d'argent de
d'intelligence de séduction chez une
femme tout de suite l'homme va se sentir
diminué et donc il aura plus de mal à
aller vers une femme qui est peut-être
qui gagne peut-être un peu plus d'argent
que ma vie il sera peut-être et donc ils
ont ramé on a tout à gagner finalement
parce que les hommes qui acceptent un
château leur dire que nous acceptions
tellement sûrs d'eux que ce sont les
bons voilà non critères qu'un versement
on va rigoler une fête de casteau emma
lourdeur parfois chez des têtes de
castor oui les théâtres qu'inversement
justement il viendra vers toi parce
qu'il est fan de toi hausse après que
prévu alors ça c'est pas possible
ça peut être le cinquième conducteur
[Applaudissements]